if you're a parent with a toddler these
kids might look familiar that's because
they are in the second most watched
YouTube hit of all time Ryan Lee is the
man behind the baby shark ear worm and
the co-founder of pink fawn a South
Korean educational entertainment company
it has made more than one hundred and
fifty million dollars thanks to YouTube
ads and merchandise sales since the
release of the video in 2016 after baby
shark
11 you jumped off 400 per fan
but now ping-pong is facing a more
crowded digital video and TV advertising
market for toddlers with all types of
creators vying for a slice of the 4.5
billion dollar pie all the while ping
pongs main source of revenue on YouTube
has been drying up so the company is
being forced to think beyond baby shark
and says it needs to turn its YouTube
hit into a true multimedia Empire if it
wants to survive we're gonna expand our
horizon you're gonna provide not only
content but also some consumer product
may be from outer experiences or theme
park
so I got on the emitter and flew down in
your name oh my god comparing government
authority Miz working on a dinosaur
series with new songs and merchandise to
cracky crucial market ping-pong never
broke into China in English baby Shah is
a very catchy but in China shock if not
that catchy I may be shocked it's quite
different right region China would be a
big win as ping-pong could tap into a
market of about 65 million kids who are
one to four years old the perfect age
bracket for its products we're at the
second floor in this floor we are
developing what will be our next a baby
shark to create a hit song for the
Chinese market ping-pong is planning to
use the same playbook it used to create
baby shark and keep toddlers eyes glued
to the screen the children's attention
span is quite shorter than the auto we
have found that it's around 90 think on
through all of the content of that
length Lee and his team also observed
thousands of children to learn which
animals are more appealing we have found
that kids actually love from fierce
animals like a dinosaur eagle and Chuck
but maybe 95% of songs only talking
about some acute animal like a rabbit
Pete funk found that kids stick around
if the videos have bright colors a lot
of quick editing and scene changes so
there's never a boring second Lee hopes
to add the China video to his catalogue
of more than 4,500 songs created over
nine years but this library has one
weakness it targets a narrow group of
viewers children aged one to four
maximum who quickly outgrow his content
we introduced the stingray character to
make the world bigger places so it's
like and not limited it to their family
so we wanted to give them rival so Lee
and his team are creating new products
for kids older than four and one part of
his grand strategy is the baby shark
movie but it doesn't stop there
for kids who want to follow the life of
baby sharks family more often there will
be TV episodes on Nickelodeon the
ultimate goal is to convert children's
eyeballs into merchandise sales to do
that pink Fong opened a brick-and-mortar
store in Seoul where parents can buy for
any age shark themed backpacks for
toddlers or projectors preloaded with
1000 ping-pong videos haha in-game yeah
I think I did it come buddy scene there
the company is planning to open pop-up
stores all over the world from New York
City to Tokyo and Dubai this merchandise
strategy has already started to work
smart study the company that owns
ping-pong nearly tripled its revenue
last year to make about 90 million
dollars but making a lot of money from
baby and toddlers eyes can be sensitive
pink fog has attracted criticism from
those who think fast paced and brash
content could have a negative impact on
children's development if it's
progressing onto the next video very
quickly it doesn't give parents and
their children time to talk about what
the children were watching and so that
they can learn from it put it into a
real-world context Gemma Taylor is a
cognitive psychologist who researches
how infants learn and retain information
she says the way videos like baby shark
are cued up on YouTube makes it hard for
them to process what they're watching
shows like Dora the Explorer for example
will talk directly to the screen this is
to get children involved and to have
some kind of interaction with the
character on the screen and so things
like that engage children and that's how
they can promote learning rather than
just having passive watching research
this content is educational reflects on
time all right for instance he says baby
shark teaches kids about family we have
a lot of fun like it teaching about the
number or shape or how to calculate
industry insiders believe this debate
has led to a shift in attitude towards
ads on YouTube videos for children which
is chipping away at ping-pongs revenue
from baby shark song puppets sing when
you move their mouth earlier this year
YouTube stopped displaying targeted ads
on kids videos following a settlement
with the Federal Trade Commission over
the data harvested from billions of
views the new rule slashed revenue by up
to 70% for many kids YouTube channels
according to the digital advertising
platform super awesome
to make up for those losses police says
the company will rely more than ever on
its dual business model mixing education
and fun we cover entertainment because
everyone pays some money maybe they're
gonna subscribe ESPN
some parents why then why they think
children doesn't need entertain
[Music]